i know that there's an outrage right now
i guess about uh protests that have been
peaceful to date and we certainly
continue to encourage that outside of
judges homes and that's the president's
position
the white house refusing to condemn
protests outside the home of supreme
court justice samuel alito critics
accusing president biden's doj of being
silent on the protests and not enforcing
a federal law which makes it illegal to
picket or parade outside a courthouse or
judge's residence in an effort to
influence a case
it's just the latest protest targeting
justices who might overturn roe v wade
a federal judge whose son was murdered
during an attack on her home speaking
out on the threats she says lawmakers
need to act now
we've been literally taking the fire for
months now years in fact
and and nothing is being done to protect
us this should not be a a partisan issue
this is an american issue and we need to
understand that public debate has a
place and that's in the public forum it
does not have a place in front of
justices or judges houses
judge i remember that that awful tragic
uh case and just to see that judge made
my make my my spine sort of sit up here
what what what are your thoughts this is
not a partisan issue this is something
that across the party lines we should
address well of course she was appointed
by president obama she lost her son he
died
her husband was shot he was on america's
news room on danish show today she was
on america's newsroom judge esther salas
in westchester we had a federal judge
who was shot by a litigant uh uh richard
duronko we named the courthouse after
him make no mistake judges are the
targets of crazed litigants uh and they
make decisions that determine the the
trajectory of one's life
and with these people who are out of
control there is a federal statute that
anticipates this kind of activity for
which there should be arrests by the fbi
prosecutions by the department of
justice now you could see them going
after the january six incidents and you
know i condemned them immediately and
said they needed to be prosecuted but
you know show a little even handedness
here this is a crime with what with what
they're doing and in the end uh if you
if you want to use your energies yelling
abort the court there are children in
those houses who are going to suffer and
there are crazed people who are going to
act on that kind of lunacy
dana what was it like with her on the
show today it was interesting i i
interviewed her when her son had just
been killed and she was very courageous
and willing to come on and today when i
talked to her in the commercial break
before the interview
i said how are you doing and she says
it's been 21 months and 18 days
so she lives with the loss of her son
front and center in her life and she
said there's nothing that they can take
away from me
and that's why she and her husband have
dedicated themselves to trying to make
sure that other judges can be protected
there's legislation that she's asked to
be passed and it has finally i think
actually because of this recent
situation it's finally maybe going to
make a move through uh the house and the
senate and become law because
it really is unfortunate that you have
to imagine if let's say the roe v wade
league decision went the other way
and there were protests the other way
right
so i guess it's okay but pretty much we
don't okay well that's true
is there a position going to be is will
the white house's position be the same
if the shoe were on the other foot and i
think that we all know the answer is no
and that's what really bothers people is
that you're just asking for the fairness
you're asking for the rule of law to be
respected you're asking for people who
are actually taken in for crimes to be
held for those crimes and not be let out
to commit other crimes i thought that
having her voice out here is so
important because she's not a republican
she's not she doesn't talk about being a
democrat i actually don't know what her
political affiliation is she is just
absolutely for the rule of law the other
thing i just want to mention is i think
senator chuck schumer might be the worst
uh majority leader in the history of the
senate do what they're going to planning
to do tomorrow is to vote have every
senator have to vote on an on a bill
that basically says
there should be a federal law that will
allow abortion up until the moment of
birth in all 50 states and they want to
make every single senator have to have
to vote on that and imagine
there's just the
disgusting nature of that to ask people
to do that i think that um there's one
thing about the judges it's the other
thing on the merits talked a lot about
the leaks but very few people are
talking about what we're actually
talking about here that's what the
senate is voting on tomorrow
ugly moments bring out ugly things uh
greg and we we're seeing it here what
what i mean from that from that
uh dana has a position about the
legislation tomorrow and obviously we
all share the view of what's happening
with these judges what should be done
what is the law that should be passed
you would think they might pass a law
the senate to protect judges as well
yeah i mean that's definitely important
they should just enforce the laws that
are already here and i have a feeling
that gensake would not even have
approached this topic if it wasn't asked
because there's a there's a there's it's
implied that there's a political
favoritism going on here i i mean the
best argument for abortion is just
watching that protest
those people should not have kids
you know
sorry but it's just like what you said
dana it just
we have moved so far
from common sense
that you could have an abortion up until
birth and that if you actually disagree
with it you're the extremist you're the
extremist so in effect there's nobody
like if you believe that you're speaking
up for something that doesn't have a
voice
you're bad you're mor you're immoral
because there's a there's a living being
that cannot speak and you're and you
want to defend that and you are
considered the extremist that is that's
an abortion of a thought i just
mentioned one other thing on ben
shapiro's podcast today he played a clip
of a leftist commentator who said that
she would happily um have sex with the
leaker yes um and then if it turned out
to be a conservative she would joyfully
abort the fetus and make sure he knew
about it
and people who want to have limits on
abortion are extremists
well remember ralph lauren northern when
he was governor he said you know she can
have the baby and then they make the
baby comfortable and the woman decides
whether or not the baby should live or
not you know why they do that because
they are terrified of planned parenthood
yeah the democrats are terrified of the
pro-choice lobby they're very powerful
and they don't want to say anything
outside of
full support of partial birth abortion
because it's going to get them in
trouble and it's going to dry up
donations because they want to stay in
power and that's what that's about
this whole violence against
trump supporters or you know this mob
thing that started in 2016. remember the
slew of attacks right against trump
supporters people getting hit in the
head with crowbars with eggs people's
cars getting torched and that was
normalized none of that was really
prosecuted none of that was ever really
talked about and then it kind of went
into the whole resistance thing remember
the resistance remember the inauguration
they firebombed the limousine there was
a lot of destruction out there in the
streets anything goes during the
administration the leaks the lies the
all that kind of stuff and then you saw
the summer of black lives matter
remember arson bailed out
throw someone down a flight of stairs
bailed out shot someone
no one ever talks about that and now
you're going to see it again this summer
and they're going to try to ride this
wave the fact that garland hasn't said a
word imagine if this was a school
superintendent's house that was being
surrounded by the things
that she went to the school board
meeting yeah they didn't go to anybody's
house yeah they stepped up to a
microphone
and waited in line yes so come on and
now you have pelosi you have schumer and
now you have the white house
okaying people surrounding public
officials homes are they really okay
with that or let that sink in that the
most powerful people in the democratic
party are okay with that and like bregg
said yesterday what happened with black
lives matter they thought that was
running real cool in the beginning in
june and july and then it started to
backfire and their neighborhoods started
to get torched and their poll numbers
started to go down watch what happens
when their homes get surrounded they're
not going to like that all right this is
mob season they have the streets they're
going to run on rogues they can't run on
anything else but inflation will beat
row and last thing
where condom
practice safe sex boys and girls all
right i know it's not perfect but
sometimes stuff happens americans are
very forgiving in the first couple weeks
but the farther you get and you start
talking about partial birth have that
conversation republicans want to have
that conversation ask the democrats
about that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else